for Jeremy Corbyn there are no longer
any limits to his ambitions even there
are motifs corners of our islands or in
insights the Western Isles SMP majority
of a thousand is one of 60 seats he
needs to win to cross the threshold of
number 10
whenever the election comes and Labour
believe it could be sooner rather than
later
and so here their leader is campaigning
in a Harris tweed Factory in Lewes and
in the rest of Scotland in days to come
and coincidentally this constituency
isn't just important to this leader
Donald Trump's mother hails from
Stornoway I'm very keen to get some
Harris tweed jacket very good yeah you
got one I mean if you get one I'll I'll
get one if you were promised you
wouldn't want it state as if you don't
run that's right listen I don't think a
state visits propriety some people have
said this week that President Trump is a
white supremacist do you think he might
be a white supremacist well I think the
remarks he made about Charlottesville
are awful and they shouldn't have made
them and I think we should just condemn
the whole idea the white supremacist and
the Ku Klux Klan and fascist turn up in
Charlottesville but do you think no I'm
not I'm not gonna go into labor in Pitt
what I'm saying is those remarks were
wrong reading the runes this
equivocation tells us how far both
politics and the labor leader have
traveled Jeremy Colvin is someone who
ran for labor leader as a politician
whose views were set in stone who always
said what he thinks but with the Jeremy
Corbyn of 2015 have not condemned Donald
Trump unreservedly would have called him
a white supremacist would have said that
as Prime Minister he wouldn't want him
to come to Britain on a state visit
I think he would probably have done all
three and the fact that he didn't that
the Corbin of 2017 doesn't say these
things tells you something it tells you
that he's thinking for the first time
like a politician like a prime minister
in Waiting I'm really struck by a
conversation earlier and a conversation
now sometimes I feel you answer very
straightforwardly as always but
nonetheless there's perhaps some of us
might think a bit more equivocation than
there might have been in the jeremy
corbyn of all perhaps because you know
now that you may well be Prime Minister
these things were going to have to
confront you think you've changed at all
over the last year I really I really
admire your powers I can't do it Sigmund
Goodall they call there is Sigmund
Goodall you're doing you're doing really
well I tell you this
I love leading the Labour Party
I'm proud of what we put forward the
election and I'm very proud that the
Labour is going to win the election so
we can bring about real social justice
for all across the UK but if he is more
mealy-mouthed than before the party
faithful don't mind a bit he's odd the
left one of their own they trust him
Jeremy Corbyn can almost smell power and
perhaps for the first time in his life
he likes it sent Louis could all Sky
News stornoway